I said he interviewed the eyewitnesses
that's what I said let's see Luke and
who are these eyewitnesses for as much
as many have taken in hand to set forth
in order a declaration of those things
which are most likely believed among us
even as they delivered them unto us
which from the beginning were
eyewitnesses I agree it says that and
Ministers of the word it seemed good to
me also having had perfect understanding
now he's saying he got it from
eyewitnesses who show you're working
which eyewitnesses which eyewitnesses if
you if you said if you said if you said
you can't just say Christians said it
the person says to you he's I'm an
eyewitness imagine if I said to you I'm
an eyewitness of Jesus Jus said you're
now or should I wait till can I respond
to it now so so what I've done I'm going
to I'm going to recap I can respond
right I'm going to recap yeah so the
first thing he never addressed the irus
thing the second thing he said we have
eyewitnesses name one eyewitness if he
goes to Mark Mark's not an eyewitness if
he goes to Luke Luke's not an eyewitness
if he goes to Matthew if he goes to
Matthew I will tell him that Matthew was
written in Greek and and the original
disciple Matthew who was uh um uh an
Israelite tax collector wouldn't have
been proficient in Greek the Greek of
Matthew so this is not this not the one
if he educated that's of he would be all
of them would be show your evidence show
your proof how do you know how do you
know Matthew how do you know Matthew was
that proficient in Greek that's your
assumption he has to be the only way you
can explain it and then using a machine
gun with all the points you're making
it's a machine gun on but if I do the
same to you oh don't machine gun me
stick with one point you're going all
over the place he was this he was that
show me this show me that 10 different
things you have
mentioned this respon to his
point but if I do
that show over he's saying that we have
no eyewitnesses when I rebutted it you
have no you do the same this is called
standing I can do this and now and now
I'm going to run away because he's going
to all things that I've mentioned 30
seconds go on I'm going to go 30 seconds
no how long will it take you to make a
he 5 minutes he said you have 30 seconds
to respond to my five minute machine gun
points that I've made all these points
every Point you're addressing run every
mention it's better for you to run away
before I before I completely humiliate
you and your prophet and your religion
as I do here
I'm about to do that this is your last
chance to get out of here if you if you
want to get out of here I'm sh your face
I'm it's you're coming across quite
aggressive you seem iate I might have
touch calm down calm down calm down if I
was to shout shout over you run I let
you speak when it was your turn you
never let me speak when it's my turn
listen listen if you don't answer the
question that I give are you listening
to me okay you see how i rate you get no
when I I didn't even and you were taking
off your mic after you said oh I've said
it you have 30 seconds to respond to my
whole speech that I just gave with all
the points I you have 30 seconds I'm
leaving right the
victim don't be scared of me friend
friend my
friend listen listen listen don't don't
be scared of me I'm not going to your
brother
ISL when the brother when the brother
came to me with the two books and
mentioned something what did you say to
me are you listening so that's why I
said to you are you listening to me okay
you didn't like it so that's all I did
was to make sure you're listening to
me yeah so everything that I've
mentioned here is in direct response to
your claims my initial claim was that
you uh how do you know ireneus you
claimed uh knew that John wrote John how
do you how can you back that up you made
the claim not me okay you didn't do it
in your first addressing to me you'd
haven't done in your second one and all
you can do is shout over me if you can't
can't address that first point then
we're done what's the point I'm asking
you questions you're not answering them
and every time you speak you just got
jumped to something else the first
question that I ask you answer that just
the first question I'm answering asking
it again just answer the first question
please but I thought you guys were
finish it can can I say something no no
no I just want to hear this guy are you
going to be sincere are you going to
answer the thing are you going to be
sincere answer the come on man I can't
do this I've been patient with you been
asking asking I've been patient with you
please irus please irus yeah you will
will
will my friend my friend my friend I
don't want to open up another kind of I
want to hear what say I want to hear
what you can speak I'm waiting for you
I'm waiting for you
now that's fine that's fine them two are
going to speak amongst themselves we can
wait for them to
finish no no no no I want him to
answer why why are you afraid of what
he's want to share I'm going to answer
is is that what you want I will do that
after he's spoken you speak to him I'm
I'm I'm no no you speak to him speak to
him I want you to all all I'm concerned
about right now is the question that
I've asked maybe 10 minutes ago 5
minutes ago how yes so I'm asking him he
made the claim I never made the claim he
made the claim please my friend it's
been it's been how many times you've
been speaking please answer the initial
claim I made the first claim please one
that told
us please so arus was challenged by the
people of his time about the
authenticity of the gospels where does
it say that I have read this in the
history what do you mean irus is in
history in the church history where
where was
irus I believe he was in Egypt right
Alexandria aland Alexandri yeah
Alexandria I'm not here for a question
you you guys do this you did the same
thing again when I start answering your
Arn question you start machine gning me
who was RNs where was he living who said
this I am
just at listen to me don't
interrupt interrup inter interr Len my
friend I let you interrupt me are you
going to interrupt me answer the
question done I'm going to write down
the name of those who questioned irnas
please okay so let's write people who of
his time were questioning him about the
authenticity of the gospel and he did
the research chur and he gave all his
evidence it's in the church history the
evidence of who wrote which gospel is
all in the history of the of the church
history that records everything how he
got the names of the people and who were
the people who transmitted it from who
so these things he did it at this time
to answer this question my who's the
name what name it's in the okay let me
say it again are are you talking about
which church history the church history
that's written in the there's a church
history there are books on church
history The Church fathers history when
you look at those church history and you
look at his history he gives the names
of the people where he got the sources
of his of his record now if you're going
to keep answering it no you keep
interrupting let me answer I'm going to
answer yeah please answer it's still can
you see that who what can you see that
who what can you see
that so scared why are you so scared my
answer you don't want to hear my answer
you don't want to answer you don't my
answer L okay so he wrote it in the
history go and read itot arus he wrote
it in his rebuttal to these people I
don't have the his book right now to
read you who are the people that he said
mentioned in there
however the chain of narration as if I
use your vocabulary was because these we
didn't need the chain of ration we just
have eyewitnesses we have people of we
have people who were following John who
were polycarp and all those people they
knew him so they knew who wrote John so
we have we we have ample evidence of our
but when I say this this is my answer
aronas you keep bringing aronas and I
said look this this is written in
history who what who wrote what you
don't have anything you have nothing you
have people my uncle said that and his
uncle said this Christians okay
Christians we don't have any PR
Witnesses who wrote the Quran where is
Abu bak's Quan you don't have anything
you just run away no no no you just took
a machine gun oh Luke wasn't this this
this oh tell me who was IR who who are
the ey Witnesses who are this and that
my friend you become very IR I'm just
demonstrating to the people that's your
mopus append that is how Muslims operate
in the power every now you're just
attacking me I am talking to you you did
the same thing attacking me now I'm
telling you this is how you do it so
tell me tell me tell me who wrote the
Quran who wrote the Quran who wrote
Surah do you have it tell me tell me now
like you ask me who tell me Aras he was
asking me I'm asking you tell me now who
wrote the Bak who wrote it that's fine
the whole who was give me the chain of
narration ofak it the whole the whole
camera everybody on camera yeah yeah who
was the witness who was the witness that
he's not answer the question
ofel no no no you running away you
running away this is how muslam is you
ask him who was the one who
saw where is the one the person who
wrote the Bak down when Muhammad was
narrating Bak who was the one who was
writing it down give me his name where
is that narration I thought he was done
what you was done anyway so I just want
to you're not answering if you're not
answering then what's Point why are you
wasting time if you're running away just
like every week Muslims do this they in
the end have to run away cuz your Islam
is undefendable you guys come up with up
you think you got something you don't
can I speak can I speak go ahead okay so
let it show that my notes that I was
going to write down the name who are
these people that checked IRAs how do we
know of this is blank he said the church
is blank everyone can see there my notes
are blank I was waiting for the name I
was waiting for the incident I was
waiting for any reference he mentioned
I'm speaking don't speak when I'm
speaking
he mentioned um church history he
doesn't mention any name what church
history I'm assuming he's referring to
uus youus is the is one of the main
Church historians yeah in in he's got
the ecclesiastical history of the church
okay so when he's go AR history you read
it there has irus got his own book of
history no no no irus is quoting how he
got do this I'm speaking I'm speaking
keep I'm speaking and and you're getting
irate when when I'm not addressing it
let me speak so um with Yus Yus is the
one that quotes irus in these previous
ones that's how we don't have like an
original manuscript from irenaeus okay
it's later church later historians that
mentioned this finny he mentioned IR uh
uus the church history if if I'm if I'm
assuming I'm going to make an assumption
here that he when he says about church
history he's saying about is cious
church history cuz that's what covers
irus and papius and polycar and these
people poly cop doesn't mention any
quote from the Gospel of John the
discussion was the christology that is
in John where did we get it from polyp
which is said to be a hero of John
doesn't quote anywhere from John in any
of the in any of the Gospel of John
where does he quote from he he quotes
from other passages in the in the Bible
from Paul's writings but he doesn't
quote from the Gospel of John now if
he's a hero of John surely he would
quote from the Gospel of John now don't
interrupt me don't interrupt me now
papus contradict
HCT but then you can't say that he's the
transm transmitter I didn't say that
second one the second one I said he the
second one the IR
the one that irus quotes to say that he
heard from John was a man called papus
now he mentioned church history and I'm
assuming he's talking about uus what
does uus say about papus he says that
papus gets things mled up that he
doesn't he doesn't he conflicts between
John the Elder and John the presbyter
and John of pmos he doesn't know which
John it is okay so this is Yus the
source that he's mentioning not I say
never fair fair point Fair camera really
for you fair fair point I did say I did
say I'm assuming he's talking about I
did not say that if if he's not talking
about that show me which other Church
Father historian from that that has a
church history is is talking about AR I
will answer that once you answer my
question hang on hang on I'm speaking
this is what you did speak I said you
will not answer my questions because
Muslims run away from my questions they
just keep answer now answer this now
answer this I won't answer anything I
think people run away from you because
you have nothing you have nothing to
answer about your Quran about your
narration hav said anything about the
things that I brought up about your what
I want is the sincere Christians to come
out and condemn this man I want the
Muslim to come out and show me how many
Muslims believe in all many like this
Christians can all the time to Muslims
say this is
SCH sincere Christian Scholars that are
out
there better than
this Muslim say no I don't believe that
it's a that's all he can do is sh over
he says Muslim run away from address it
okay are you going to address it why
don't you address it are you afraid of
your religion you why are you you you
Haven you don't want to address it
listen if I
can't so just say I lost I can't address
your your questions because I cannot
Islam is undefendable say it listen my
friend because you can't defend it
there's no shame there is no shame in
saying Muslims don't believe in sah
Hadith if the S Hadith does
not the Quran or does not affir the
Quran that
narration the narration imagine working
with a person like this look at this
personal attack because he has no this
is Islam when you cannot address the
question attack the person just attack
me because you can't attack the question
me many times earlier said one thing
back to him and now he's the victim
again no no no I am the victim because
you haven't addressed a single question
when are you going to answer done I
think we're
done done that every Muslim believes in
all
the bro you can not answer it I'm
sorry I'm going to finish it on
my
I'm sorry to keep taking them off this
guy's a headache this guy's a headache
firstly I just want to say that yeah
yeah you
do that the this cannot be this this guy
does not represent Christianity at all
yeah first I want to say that from the
GetGo go because in was to expose him
yeah so so there's many Christians that
are that are well versed in what we're
talking about and are able to address
these things and have these
conversations and go and go to some some
depth okay unfortunately this guy he
just you can see he's got an agenda um
he just wants to kind of shout over
people and and and speak the idea about
chain of transmission he said Christians
were the ones that gave it to him that
that doesn't help us with he again
imagine if we took a Hadith and we say
this Hadith has been narrated by Muslims
and that's our only criteria is that it
was narrated by Muslims this is not this
is not acceptable the Muslims have to
show their chain of narration their
transmission we mentioned there was five
before this uh start recording we
mentioned there were five conditions for
authentic Hadi uh one of them is
precision one of them is upright in
character connection of chain uh uh not
not um not contradicting that which is
stronger than it than than not
contradicting that which is stronger
than it and other conditions as well
yeah
so and no defect no yeah of course
exactly exactly no hidden defect exactly
so we mentioned this and we said this is
what we would need in order for someone
to say this Hadith is and we can accept
this Hadith that's the first part in
terms of the and the understanding of
the Hadith again there's still there's
still a layer of scholarship that we
have to go through how do we understand
these
things it's still there still that kind
of level now for him he can attack us
and say you take from your uncles and
this one your grandads or whatever no we
don't that's we wouldn't accept that the
Hadith would be if if someone is unknown
person we cannot accept
it again okay um so this is the so again
he mentioned we have eyewitnesses
Matthew is not an eyewitness the one who
wrote this this an assumption they have
that the author of Matthew is Matthew
the auor of John is John the auor of
Luke is Luke the auor of Mark is Mark
these are an assumptions we need to test
them first Matthew is written in highly
polished Quin Greek as many non-muslim
scholars would attest to that this is
like a high
of uh Greek language so Matthew was a
tax collector yes he would have known
some Greek yes he would have known uh
some of the language of the Romans that
he's that he's collecting taxes for but
would he be highly polished no it
doesn't necessitate that if he was
demonstrate it that's an assumption okay
so Matthew we can assume he's not an
it's unlikely that he's an eyewitness
okay and the Matthew that we have was
not written in Hebrew we know the early
church fathers they mentioned and they
made mention of a of of of a Matthew the
disciple who wrote a gospel in Hebrew
known as The Gospel to the Hebrews okay
which is which is coincidental as well
cuz we know that in the time in in in in
Mecca he would write the Gospel in
Hebrew so it wasn't a Greek gospel the
layer before these ones that we have now
these gospels that we have it was the
original teachings of Jesus what was
jesus' primary audience they were Hebrew
speaking Aramaic speaking According to
some opinions um so we want to know that
layer before Greek cuz we know as we
know as well that the translator is from
the isnad so if you if you know if you
don't know the translator the translator
is transmitting information to you and
he's also trying his best to put it from
one one language to another he is from
the chain of transmission the trans the
translator is from the isad so if you
don't know who wrote The Greek then how
can you say how can you say that we have
uh we have eyewitnesses and you have
your uncles and your aunties that we
taking from know that you men you
explain which one mention that book of
John he told to read at the end so at
the end of John it says now now this is
the disciple who who wrote these things
I'm paraphrasing but you can check it
John 21 this is a disciple who wrote
these things and we testify that his
testimony is true so what is what is
talking somebody I Thea is speaking in
the first person plural so we so he's
saying we we testify we bear witness
that what he has said is is true so okay
that sounds good but who's the weak if
someone comes now and says I uh I've got
a a blank manuscript here and it says we
testify that Jesus said that John said
that Jesus said x y and Zed we're not
going to how can you accept it because
you don't know who is the wi who is
giving you the transmission so this is
why and and why John is so um important
is because John has the highest
christology Mark has a lower christology
very human this is the earliest gospel
Jesus is very human Matthew and Luke is
kind of elevated but it's still synoptic
he still in the same view John is highly
highly kind of spiced up a highly
exalted view of Jesus if you look in the
previous uh the synoptic gospels Mark uh
Matthew and Luke you'll see that Jesus
if you look when when did he uh when was
he become Son of God uh was it was it on
the day of the baptism was it when he
was crucified look at John John he was
there before Abraham was I am he's
always been there so the elevation of
Jesus's status is is is primarily in
John outside the churches when you want
to see the the big quotes is um I am the
way the truth and the life when you ask
a Christian where where does it say that
Jesus said he was God ah before Abraham
was I am I am the way and the truth the
life um all the Great I Am statements
it's well known okay so that's the
source of the high christology not to
say that markis is a Muslim gospel or
Matthew and but we can see an elevation
the later on you go the higher the
christology the further back you you go
the lower the christology now if you go
before Mark which is before all of the
the the gospels Mark is the First Gospel
written that they they have if you go
before that what we would see is that
you find a a Jesus that is exactly the
same as the Jesus of the Quran and this
is what historians are saying and
there's a there's a a book called James
and the James and the church or James
the brother of Jesus by jeffre buts
amazing book he highlights this point
he's he's from I think he from Michigan
University of Michigan he highlights
this point and he shows that uh the the
the key to understanding the true Jesus
from a historical point of view is James
and when you see that James who prayed
in the temple who told him to worship
the god of Israel who viewed the only
difference he he differed with the Jews
is viewing that Jesus was the Messiah
this is how we differed with the Jews
now this James and this historical Jesus
Jeffrey buts mentions that it it it
lines up exactly with the Muslim Jesus
and we can see this we can see that when
we we understand these things
and we take away the layers that's been
added on from these unknown scribes and
unknown sources you can see that a pure
Islamic Jesus who pray to God they can
even see in their own text there's still
remnants in there for them to see the
Lord's Prayer our father is who are in
heaven Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done on Earth as it is
in heaven give us this day our daily
bread and forgive us our trespasses as
we forgive those who trespass against us
what's apart from the word Father which
we have some issues later on now with
Islam the word father we have the some
issues with that apart from that if you
understand that Jesus is telling the
disciples to pray to his Lord he's
telling them to pray to the father this
is this is they still have it in John as
well this is true life that they may
know you the only true father so the
clear and ambiguous statements are there
to show that Jesus prayed to God he got
he has a God he taugh others to pray to
God he told others to to to submit and
humble themselves to this God and that
that you would have faith if you humble
whoever humbles himself will be made
highest and whoever makes himself high
will be humbled so this is this is what
this is what the the teaching of Jesus
was okay now we have these people and
they just you can see you can see
alhamdulillah so again this is why when
the prophet Muhammed PE upon Him Not
only was he prophesized in their
scripture he's expected why would he
expect why is why do we say it's
expected because if their book has been
corrupted unknown unknown authors
manuscripts differ with each other um
people just fabricate in the name in the
name of Jesus we have these things um uh
it's only right that God would send a
prophet afterwards to clarify so not
only is he prophesized in the in their
Bible many times he's also expected
there needs to be another Prophet
because this scripture is corrupted so
Allah has sent his last prophet mhammad
wasallam to clarify for these things
just to mention some of the prophecies
that are maybe not as well known our
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him um uh
uh the companions came to him and they
said we we know how to send Salam upon
you but how do we send Salat upon you
taught them uh the the we say
the then he also
said we find in Genesis in chapter 12 it
says a promise to Abraham we know the
promise to to is that is that Allah will
make him a great nation the what the
Christian all of them are aware of the
pro the promise to Isaac and the Jews
are aware of the Propet to Isaac they
highlight on that one that the Covenant
will be with him there's also uh a uh
but we believe the Covenant was taken
but there's also a covenant and a
blessing for ibraim and that is I will
bless those who bless you so daily every
day the Muslims we and and and you and
it says I will bless those who bless you
and your name will be used as a blessing
okay never in history do we have as many
people today day sending um uh blessing
upon ibraim and using his name to send
Blessing on others
like as we do today with the Advent ofam
um he mentions in
uh his his book in Quran he mentions
regarding the of
the he mentions in the of that that this
affirmation this that we do this that we
do is an it's a reaffirmation of the
original blessing upon ibraim so we
bless ibraim
daily we say this daily okay and we do
it in our and we use his name as a
blessing but this has never happened
with anybody other than the Advent ofam
and Allah mentioned that he would do
that he would make his name a blessing
why because ibraim left his land he made
hij from the land of the mus when you
make Hijra from somebody your name
becomes unknown your lineage becomes
unknown but whe and and your wealth uh
becomes
uh